every town the town in which you and I
live in the north south east or west our
homes our work our recreations make
every town what it is every town is on
the move
winging in the rhythm of the United
States
yes in every town happiness and security
are challenged daily by an enemy this
enemy strikes often estat give his name
is tuberculosis here is a germ that
causes this disease all of us in every
town bear the burden of tuberculosis but
it weighs heaviest on cold loved ones
that attacked an awesome cake
tuberculosis bless the whole appearance
parents who have made uncounted
sacrifices for their children to break
your altars maker of orphan
every town kings within the sphere in
the Russian home the enemy and his
victims are easily forgotten the use of
every town glory in the spring there's
less for life yet to prickle OSes
destroys 32,000 Americans under 40 each
year
here is Roy he is young he is strong his
unafraid he has helped and Red Bull
and here in another of every town's many
industries is julie eager incapable yes
that quitting bill has a welcome sound
when the day's work is done
life now really digging for Jewish
why is the same way about his whistle
black
man speaking for Julian live when they
meet at the factory door the old jalopy
coughs and snorts what is still those
places to the rainbow for instance a
rosy rainbow of products
the young Americans in every town will
work hard play hard to get a fun
companionship these are topics of normal
every town life
boy and generally wouldn't miss their
holiday swim for anything building
health and strengthen the pressure
carefree and happy
whoa what is this a hemorrhage from the
lungs every towns health Guardians along
the job ready to serve anymore
luckily for why there's a first-rate
sanatorium in every town blood from the
bowels the physician knows is not to be
touched up like these experienced and
skilled eyes and ears suck down the
cause of that hemorrhage get the packs
together all the odds and ends effects
human blood samples are taken and also
go to the laboratory and very important
the magic eye of the x-ray
only a shadow picture is for these but
the trained eye can read what's behind
the shadows as clearly are you read a
page of a book the student sample is
flipped from a rigid test the microscope
aids the germ unmistakeable to the
medical staff defect spills tuberculosis
of the left lung active far advanced and
with the cavity but if Y plays the game
is chances are good treatment absolute
fit red and says the chief of staff
bring this case up for review in one
month to break you lose this certainly
changes Laura's life it puts a certain
stuff to work and play and plan for the
future
Weston Morris West for ROI but not for
the case finders every talent health
workers know that each case of
tuberculosis comes from some other case
public health nurses inquire from whom
did Roy get it to whom has he given it
find out from his employer about his
workmates if someone there who gave the
disease to him if there's someone else
to whom Roy may have given it this is
how the germ gets from one body to
another
now thorough but Texel detective work
finds out about lawyers home his word
his close associates the nurse follows a
big news Roy's friends are interested
here comes the clue easy to follow Julie
where does she live this nurse is a
contact finder
do you remember Julie that was lip
contact the surest way of transporting
tuberculosis germs
don't delay Julie let the doctor decide
and Julie visits her physician besides a
routine examination of the chest the
examination includes the tuberculin test
a simple skin test which tells whether
to Brickey losest germs have found a
foothold in the body up-to-date
physicians everywhere now use this test
if negative it means no tuberculosis if
positive it means search further
Julie return the test is positive the
spot where the solution was injected a
slightly raised and British
Julie must be x-rayed
here are the shadows expertly
interpreted by the doctor they say early
to pretty roses
don't delay Julie that sooner treatment
has begun the more certain secure bed
rest now for Julie almost add vegetable
existence this but reading notes good
reading habits help Julie as they have
so many others to readjust to rely a
friendly place the sanatorium the
medical Qi talks to all of the patients
by such means modern sanatoria
educate their patients in a new way of
life listening with all the patience to
what the doctor said
our sanatorium is but one of the
many-faced hospitals of a great warfare
here we train doctors nurses technical
workers who carry on the battle the
sanatorium is a place to care for sick
people and restore them to a useful life
here the resources of medical science
are put into practice and the treatment
of the patient and the defeat of
tuberculosis outside our sanatorium are
other forces Health Department health
workers educators who plan the
strategies the tuberculosis Association
brings the story of tuberculosis to the
public by printed matter I'm the picture
screen over the air throughout the
country tuberculosis associations
sanctify the National tuberculosis
Association on every town to make war on
the enemy for the physician technical
publication information all this made
possible by the sale of Christmas seals
Julie listens and live Sunday she will
become one of the soldiers fighting
tuberculosis but first comes the
business of getting better and that
means rest
what news of LOI after weeks of bed rest
the extra shadow till noise doctor that
the cavity in the longest still open the
germs are still in his feudin he needs
special treatment the doctor arranges
for Roy a simple operation called
pneumothorax a local anesthetic comes
first
very gently air is allowed to enter
between the rigid chest wall and the
soft lung tissue by means of a series of
these simple operations the diseased
lung is compressed long enough to heal
meanwhile wise doctor calls a staff
meeting to study Roy as a person the
librarian reports what he reads
the Occupational Therapist explores
rising waves
I'm the nerd
Roy's heart interest is no secret of his
nurse from the state rehabilitation
agent the doctor learns more about Roy's
former job he must kick this off to the
whole train staff helps the ductus to
understand Roy and his problem
time things into this end new privileges
for Roy the state rehabilitation agent
knows about jobs and training for jobs
Laura's doctor calls on this knowledge
to help plan a new life for Roy
first why needs to know himself how fast
and how accurately can Roy do clerical
work does he have mechanical aptitude
how readily does he sleep pattern size
design
how well the voice two hands work
together
has he much knack for handling small to
the answers to such questions boy a lot
about himself now the doctor couples
what he knows about Roy with what the
rehabilitation agent knows of jobs and
training
together they discussed various
occupations
a final rehabilitation plan has worked
out with and for Roy
the rehabilitation agents and Royce
former employer work out a retraining
plan in a growing industry boy continues
to improve he earns further privileges
ah
what a privilege it is that the Monson
bed just to amble out of doors
however leisure should not mean idleness
boy learns new forms have played more
suitable to his condition immense
hobbies may have much to do with it
and then there's Julie but what job
shall Julie be trained Fung making is a
job to keeping house efficiently Affairs
energy and saves money
Julie will need her energy to keep well
a smooth-running job even in
housekeeping is less tiring but doctor
knows that well
so Julius taught how to avoid hard ways
in home making one can learn to work
more efficiently
one day of graduation from the
sanatorium comes at last
and it's goodbye to the sanatorium but
Roy takes with him what he has learned
rehabilitation now go to him
full speed a medical check-up is not
neglected the healed longing holds firm
Roy's training is checked by the
rehabilitation agents it leads to a job
Roy has been helped to prepare for a job
he can do the low back always long and
often tu leaves at last to happiness
Roy and Julie they have found the way
back the war against tuberculosis goes
on in every town their close escape from
disaster makes new recruits of war and
Julie they have seen active service and
casualties they seek we must meet with
all who a defence against tuberculosis
their experience may know our young
people to avoid disaster their interests
will last for the duration of the war
citizens of every town English white-box
tuberculosis in Macau